in the depths of Britain's PPE crisis
last month there came an offer of help
from Turkey but right from the start
there was confusion today I can report
that a very large consignment of PPE is
due to arrive in the UK tomorrow from
Turkey which amounts to 84 merely 84
tons of PPE and will include for example
400,000 gowns that promise proved hollow
the equipment didn't arrive the next day
and we hope to see that coming into the
country
hope to see that coming into the country
tomorrow or the next only getting here
another two days after that we're
working to resolve the Turkish shipment
of PPE as soon as possible following
some unexpected delays at the weekend we
can now reveal that only a fraction of
the 400,000 gowns ministers said Braun
their way in planes from Turkey have
ever arrived in fact of them only four
and a half thousand that's one percent
have passed quality control tests so
they can be used in Britain's hospitals
the government today was focusing on the
positive at least it said it showed the
checks are working and I'm pleased that
our Health Service experts and
professionals are assessing equipment
and only using equipment of a fit ease
of a good enough standard and this is a
good example of where we are a country
that's going to make sure that the
frontline staff have the very best
equipment but it emerged that 170,000 of
the gowns are still in Turkey awaiting
checks there by Turkish authorities the
Turkish government says this was a
contract between the UK and a private
supplier and has nothing to do with them
the Turkish government it said
authorized this sale despite an export
ban out of solidarity with the UK
authorities however no part of the
Turkish government was involved in
producing packaging or delivering said
equipment to the United Kingdom so while
the Health Service is desperately needed
PPE throughout this crisis more than
three-quarters of the 400,000 gowns were
never put on a plane in Turkey of those
that reach the UK most have failed tests
or are still waiting to be checked the
NHS Confederation says it hopes that
ministers have learned
and from this Fiasco there is a real
danger in promising things that you
can't absolutely be sure are going to be
delivered and that matters more during
this pandemic than it normally does when
politicians make promises by one
estimate British hospitals have been
using 150,000 gowns a day in this crisis
of the 400,000 gowns promised the four
and a half thousand that actually passed
tests would have made little difference
and the British government is still
waiting for the rest dominic Waghorn Sky
News